what's up collider TV talk fans Josh
McKoon here with dad Williams and a
special guest today on your episode of
TV talk one of the stars of Mayans
he plays angel and it would honestly one
of our favorite characters hands down
Cardenas man thank you so much I
appreciate you so I think when we
started was we were huge Sons of Anarchy
fans you know what I mean and when
Mayans started I was really excited
because there were so many different
incantations of this show that had
talked about before you talk about like
your process of how you got involved
with the show and then you know over the
last couple seasons yeah it was
interesting I was a sons fan as well
okay coach huge fan a fan of kim coates
Charlie Hunnam Kim Coates was just in
here look he's he's the best yeah that's
that to me I mean actors but that's an
actor yeah yeah the way you can
shape-shift and it's just about right
but for me when I first heard about the
project it was maybe six it was right it
was about six months before it got
greenlit and this this agent that I had
she said if mines ever gets greenlit
you're gonna be in mind and it was
interesting so that I really had that
momentum and I was like oh so yeah you
know what you know and then it got
Greenland six months later
yeah I go in to audition with Wendy
O'Brien she goes with a casting for
John's and for mines as well and I
remember and you sometimes we get roles
and you just know like I'm sorry but
nobody else can play this but me I just
had that firm belief right just firm and
just understanding and knowing yeah um
so I go and I do the read and she stops
me like right at the end she's like
where the hell have you been all my life
Wow in that moment I knew she's like
she's like do you want to read again
she's like oh my like strikes writing
strike as a next day I meet with um Kurt
Sutter
yeah knows it man yeah he said you know
he doesn't give you like an affirmative
like you got it he's like I think I
think he likes me
I don't know but yeah the next day we
got any we got rolling my damn that's
awesome that's awesome now were you
proficient with motorcycles before the
show no there's a lot of footage of me
falling stalling there's a shot that uh
the social media team for mines effects
they haven't mean I'm literally driving
towards an 18-wheeler because I didn't
know the clutch I didn't understand the
clutch and you see all the guys because
there's video of them watching me you
see lo the Kazakh right the last second
I just beer off to the right no I was
scared you know it's it's a lot
different I grew up on dirt bikes and
quads okay but that's a different beast
yeah you going to Harley's those things
almost a thousand pounds right it just
to turn it around is a lot of forearm
strength right I had it develop there
was the scene in this season when you
guys are at the the flying eagle ranch
something were where the shootout goes I
would want our boy Antonio Jaramillo
kind of takes the fatal shot yeah when
they light those motorcycles up I was
just thinking to myself and like so the
some of the sons would take I mean I'm
sorry Tommy and I'm happy and [ __ ] chibs
yeah they were so they were they had it
they had a scene where they had to pull
off I remember they pulled off smooth
and fast like lightning and like all the
mines look at each other like oh sure I
guess that's how it's looking that cool
that fast
focus I mean your sons when Kim was in
here last week it was so funny we do a
live show every day 10 to 12 and then I
came out and kim coates is standing
right there was like what the that's
cool we loved you in Suns like the great
seven years so after seven years of
running on that show and you you know
Kurt Sutter not exactly known for his
brevity of episodes right so you know
it's seven years of motorcycle
experience you know you guys are now the
little baby brother but you got a third
season we got a third season man we're
all really excited yeah I'm very happy
I'm very happy that you know the fans
support it and love it as much as we do
you know cuz we really do put our heart
and soul into it and so we hope that it
shows right so yeah and the reactions we
get from the fans is like you know wow
this is the first time I've in a long
time that you know I've never been able
to speak with my family
my father and then like this is the
communal bond watching the show and like
you hear stories like that oh wow this
is bigger than me just [ __ ] acting
right right this has such a trickle-down
effect no I didn't really understand
that in beginning but now I have the
understanding of that and I hold that
close yeah speaking of fathers what's it
like working with Edward James Olmos as
your dad you know what man I was a first
day I was nervous very nervous yeah you
know I know his legend was list of but I
remember he uh he kind of pulled me
aside he's I and he said you're in the
same place as me and and then he walked
away and so I analyzed it I was like oh
he meant like you look man we're both on
the same set we're both on the same show
if I'm if I'm here you're good enough to
be here as well so that kind of just
calmed my nerves that's a badass thing
oh that ass yeah and I learned to
laughing man he teaching me a lot about
technical stuff
camera stuff you know stuff that you'd
be 20 years in the game to really have
an understanding sure um but he'll take
the time you like no no look he'll tell
me you know look right here on the
camera don't look here look right here
yeah and like just those little notes it
goes such a long way when you see it
it's amazing this you know I appreciate
him very much
it's let's say this season was I mean
last season obviously you and easy had
like an awesome arc sure this season
kind of obviously started then you guys
bill I would say at the end there you
guys have never been more brothers than
you were quite obviously at the end of
the yeah I mean you know started off the
season wine you know easy was trying to
not console his brother but trying to
mend that relationship right so you saw
these this friction and then as these
you know these problems came about you
see them come together and bond and you
know I think that's the beauty I think
that's what people want to see right you
know we do obviously if you have
siblings you do bicker and you know mess
around with each other but in the end
you love each other on the end when it
comes down to it we stick together and
so I think that's what you got to see at
the end of the season yeah I think I
Potter might be one of my favorite
villain in TV anyway Hey
I want him to die he's messing with your
kid now he's messing with my kid with my
family yes my baby mom he's messing with
my father like he's the perfect villain
you're right and yes there's a lot of
times where a villain like that can be
like - like mustache twirling yeah
but he's like and he has been since sons
right he's been that really really good
villain
you're the season finale this season I
mean we both texted each other meaning
like holy [ __ ] man
I mean not only did we not see most of
that coming you guys have that crazy
seen you and easy right and your father
yeah can you talk about like the
creation of that scene which I'm sorry
where you light up DITA oh the creation
of that scene that was interesting so we
had we had almost a full day to shoot
that scene okay and no it was it was you
know it was very Shakespearean and
mother for mother and um but just the
the gruesomeness of it right yes the
just just just the act of you know
seeing easy choke her out and then me
coming over cold and just dumping
gasoline on her you know you really get
to see like I think for the boys it's a
gets the consolation prize
yeah a sense for you know their mother's
death right so it's like you know heart
for heart on that man right it was a
long day it was a long day cuz they
wanted to shoot at different ways and
there's only so much you could show and
not show so that was you know the
logistics of it was probably the most
challenging part okay yeah and you you
also got to kind of you and you and easy
got to help bridge the Suns mythology a
lot with that episode when you went up
to charming and confronted happy I mean
that was I feel like that was the
beginning of a lot of the gruesome
nature when trying to trying to get
revenge for your mother right you see
yeah you see just the callousness and in
the boys yeah especially with the you
talk about seeing what we have on
cutting yeah you know what's funny is um
so I have a I'm using a rubber knife and
they put these this fake patches of skin
so I could cut and you had all these
happy tattoos yeah yeah and so those are
always kills yes taken into him
and [ __ ] I'm digging into the wrong
one that's not that's a real piece of
his skin I felt like a very like a very
sons episode because there was a couple
of times episode you guys about a couple
where you know most of the episode kind
of takes place in that one apartment
there's a lot of moving parts within
like a very small area a small space can
you talk about like the shooting of that
dog barking you know interesting so we
shot that in we shot that in sequence
normally we don't we shoot all over
scene then it's fought five and then we
shooting thirty for the night
we got to shoot that also it was like it
was like doing a play for us which was
great because there was a lot of
dialogue like I said and it's all
tightened in one zone those were long
days and I remember DL David had had
it's a pretty sizable monologue right
right and we could tell he had been
working on hard and I remember he was
like man this is the most I've talked to
since he's great man David is like a
good dude right in the soul he's not
happy he's not happy you know he's
definitely he's definitely a character
though but you love having around yeah
anyway he uh yeah you could tell he had
rehearsed and uh and he asked he's like
hey do you guys mind if I go first
meaning we shoot all his coverage first
yeah and you know like some people think
that's not the cool thing to do but like
you saw how much he we saw how much he
worked at it and saw how much heart he
put into a lay man hell yeah yeah do
this first and he nailed it man he's a
great he did a great job you put it in a
stellar performance probably my favorite
episode of the season mine too yeah yeah
mine too yeah for sure for shooting it
sorry I got it sorry man
just thinking about the show so we you
know there's been a lot in the news
right now about Kurt and right what's
going on with the show and anything I
don't know what you're able to kind of
talk about or what are your experience
like with Kurt you kind of talked about
it like what was going on in the show
personally I never had any problems you
know hurts my dog yeah you know he put
me on literally put me on the map and
you know his creative processes his
creative process
you know and if it takes a long time to
get the the words and to get those kind
of stories and so be it yeah I do
understand though that put some kind of
stress on other departments yeah you
know because um people have to find
locations people have to know wardrobe
you know there's so many different
moving parts in this whole you know
piece of art that we're creating yeah so
yeah man you know I there's nothing
there's nothing you know that I could
say but you know we do support Elgin
James yeah you know we're excited to be
working with him and you know hear his
fresh stories and you know Curt wouldn't
back him and give him the baton if he
didn't believe that he could write it
hold the show up
is there uh you know going into season
three is there something that what do
you want to happen obviously I want part
of the dive yes I want to at your hands
at my hands yeah yeah you know simple as
that I want to see more of the Reyes
brothers together you know going on
expeditions and you know I love the fact
that you know he finally got patched in
and the final a boy knows I mean thank
God because he was missing so many good
see this from a fans point of view
you're missing so much not being in the
temple oh yeah oh so now he's in there
so now we get to see you know this
beautiful boy in there you know I want
to see that I want to see how angel you
know I want to see angel
go get out Aleta yeah I want to see him
get his baby and then I want to see how
he can have agates having a child while
being in the MC I think that's a
challenge in itself you know a part of
me and part of Clayton wants angel to
think about living a life outside of the
MC yeah hopefully being the father that
his father wasn't you know so I'd like
to see a little bit of that I'd like to
see more there's I don't we need to see
more sex
[Laughter]
is no sex last year there was you know
its sons if anything like there's a lot
of sex hot people and people you
wouldn't think am I seeing like the one
half season they were running like a
porn ring yeah because like we were kind
of getting like an easy love interest
there for a second which I'm guessing is
kind of like setting up a three man I
did this show when it first started I
was you know I was jonesing for more
sons yeah
and how season 2 ended i think we're
getting back which I love is that sons
Mayans rivalry which we had kind of like
glazed over it's a great modern-day NBA
right here we go LeBron and choir like
best buds and of being worse than
enemies now the minds in the center
that's you know that I think we you know
the fans aunt and the actors they want a
lot of that too you know it's awesome
you know you guys it's always
challenging doing a first season because
you have to introduce characters there's
a lot of like in a sense boring stuff
that has to be laid out so everybody
knows and usually season two three
that's when stuff gets rockin right so
yeah I mean it'll be I think we can
almost live off you know the next five
seasons off just Suns and mines battles
oh right I agree and now and now with
the vatos my peoples yeah I love that
yeah the three-way war now you see a
little bit in two tosses passed to the
club and you know you could tell that
Pablo has a secret on the Oz of that he
doesn't want to be known and we saw in
the in the finale there's the picture
that toss looks at that that's supposed
to be his bro cousin cousin cousin I
believe yes so there's something
interesting in that yeah even the
picture of the dude was interesting I'm
like that's an interesting
[Laughter]
yeah you guys go back and look at that
picture and analyze that picture yeah
you know I mean for sure listen man I
know appreciate you coming in we love
the show I can't can't wait for a season
three I got I mean like I said we were
so excited for the show and it's more
than lived up to expectations and I
think you're one of the major major
reasons that that's happening man
so thank you again thank you for coming
in thanks for thanks for making the show
clay Cardenas here on clatter TV talk
the full episode you guys can check out
and subscribe to the channel all that
kind of stuff and watch my ins on FX
everything is streaming now on the FX FX
app go right to it absolutely should be
hidden Hulu soon yeah absolutely awesome
all right thanks